gab ziemlichen aufruhr kürzlich als
bekannt wurde im bundestag gelten andere
corona regeln als für alle anderen
nämlich der genesenen status wurde er
verkürzt von sechs monate auf drei aber
nicht im bundestag unverschämtheit
nannte das einer der abgeordneten
alexander dobrindt er hier und mit der
meinung stand er nicht alleine da wir
haben das ganze jetzt mal zum anlass
genommen um zu gucken gilt für die
politik generell oder zumindest häufiger
ein anderer maßstab praktischerweise
waren jetzt gerade zwei
parteiveranstaltungen von den grünen und
die csu da musste ich hin um darüber zu
berichten und da habe ich dann mal
geschaut wie wird das denn da konkret so
gehandhabt mit den krone regeln kleiner
spoiler es gab überraschung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die frage kommt hier nicht zum ersten
mal auf gelten für die politik andere
regeln zum beispiel kurz nach der
bundestagswahl hat sich die neue
spd-fraktion zum gruppenfoto
[Applaus]
tja das hier ok zu finden und zum
beispiel volle fußballstadien schlimmen
das ist zumindest schwierig zu erklären
einer hat es trotzdem versucht mit dem
erklären bei der kollegin meischberger
bei der ist allerdings ja so ein
bisschen an die falsche geraten trotzdem
haben die leute hier nichts falsch
gemacht weil das foto wurde schnell
gemacht sind laut haben wurde die maske
abgezogen das tut den ländlichen
autobauer muss ich sie korrigieren wir
haben das bild in bewegt dann können sie
über gucken wie schnell das war dass die
leute da die maske abgezogen haben es
wurde lange geklatscht dann wurde noch
mal kam nochmal der fraktionsvorsitzende
mitte und jetzt ist der moment wo der
kanzler kandidat olaf scholz noch dazu
kommt also ich könnte jetzt auch noch
weiterlaufen lassen es gab la ola wellen
und jubel das ist ein super special
event im moment oder wäre es wenn dort
gesungen wurde laut gesprochen wurde
nicht gesungen nicht laut gesprochen
was meint ihr stark erklärt
oder muss man vielleicht sagen ist gar
nicht so stark erklärt oder vielleicht
sogar der erklärungsversuch ist am ende
möglicherweise sogar noch
problematischer als das event an sich
weil politiker wollen ja ernst genommen
werden mit dem was sie sagen vor allem
der gesundheitsminister wenn sie aber
einerseits immer warnen auf der anderen
seite aber so was ja dann eher klein
reden dann ist das lobby für die
glaubwürdigkeit nicht ganz so toll aber
trotzdem haben die leute hier nichts
falsch gemacht letzte woche dann eben
die meldung sonderrechte genießen den
status im bundestag gilt weiterhin sechs
monate offizielle begründung der
genesenen status sei wie es wörtlich
heißt in der allgemeinverfügung des
bundestages geregelt und die habe man
nach der neuen regelung noch nicht
angepasst also die begründung verstehe
ich nicht ganz heißt ja grob übersetzt
wir halten uns nicht an die regeln weil
wir bei uns diese regeln nicht
eingeführt haben das sind dann ja ganz
objektiv zweierlei maß warum das möglich
ist und warum es vielleicht sogar
berechtigt ist da komme ich später
darauf zurück jetzt erstmal der
versprochene schlüsselloch blick auf die
parteien daher gab sich nämlich wie
gesagt jetzt kalendarischer zufall die
gelegenheit die probe aufs exempel zu
machen bei der csu und zuvor den grünen
[Musik]
bundesparteitag beziehungsweise wie es
bei den grünen heißt
bundesdelegiertenkonferenz das war eine
so genannte hybrid veranstaltung heißt
ein teil der delegierten war vor ort
einen teil digital zugeschaltet medien
waren vor zugelassen auch sie mussten
sich natürlich halten an dieses
zweieinhalb seitige hygiene konzept hier
mit unter anderem ziemlich strengen
einlass voraussetzungen sind hier im
berliner velodrom ihr findet das ganze
statt einlass voraussetzungen also man
braucht entweder nachweis dass man
geimpft ist oder gelesen also zweig plus
und tagesaktuelles testergebnis weil das
eine zweitägige veranstaltung ist sogar
jeden tag einen also zwei tests entweder
aus dem schnell test centers und bürger
test den ja jeder kostenlos bekommt oder
man kann sich das auch wie ich hier wenn
man geld sparen will vom arbeitgeber
zertifizieren lassen das ganze unter
aufsicht machen dass also im grunde
dasselbe wie jeder normale machen muss
wenn er zum beispiel das restaurant will
unterschied diesen tagesaktuellen test
muss man auch dann vorweisen wenn man
gepustet ist also sozusagen zweig + + ja
und hier drin sind die regeln auch
ziemlich klar noch mal aufgeschrieben
schütze dich und andere weil symptom zu
hause bleiben
händewaschen
desinfizieren und hier natürlich maske
tragen in innenräumen und vermeide
körperkontakt mit anderen und halte zu
ihnen mindestens anderthalb meter
abstand guck mal rein wie das 1 1 ja
also insgesamt war mein eindruck über
die zwei tage dass sich die anwesenden
tatsächlich ziemlich diszipliniert
gehalten haben an die regeln der man
sieht hier große abstände zwischen den
sitzplätzen insgesamt war die halle auch
nicht annähernd so voll wie bei anderen
parteitagen in der vergangenheit so
dritte digitale parteitag und das für
das digitale parteitags ist ein
wattestäbchen in der nase über sich dann
jeden tag testet um das risiko möglichst
gering zu halten allerdings gab es wie
im echten leben natürlich auch momente
wo das dann eben leichter gesagt ist als
getan
mit den regeln zum beispiel bei der
verabschiedung von herrn kellner den wir
im rat gehört haben der nach acht jahren
als bundesgeschäftsführer abgetreten ist
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja das wird ein schweres bei der eigenen
verabschiedung dann verhält man sich
schon mal um den arm mit der maske das
ist eine überwälzung der gefühl habe und
das ist ja finde ich völlig verständlich
völlig menschlich frage ist bloss kann
man es dann anderen verwehren alle
anderen also wir normalos umarmen uns ja
auch eigentlich nur dann wenn wir
zumindest subjektiv gesehen ein grund
dafür haben auch da die frage wie seht
ihr das schreibt rein und nochmal dieses
thema begleitet uns jetzt schon eine
ganze weile bevor wir gleich auf die csu
gucken im vergleich noch mal ein kurzer
rückblick das mit dem regeln einhalten
und zwar dann wenn es schwerfällt ist ja
schon viele nicht ganz so gut gelungen
und zwar in sämtlichen wellen der
pandemie in der ersten zum beispiel emir
christian lindner dafür hatte einen
ordentlichen shitstorm gekriegt nun kann
man sagen er war jetzt nie so der ganz
große verfechter strenger regeln gilt
nicht so sehr für sie hier jetzt gleich
ein foto von angela merkel von anfang
november
2021 also vor ein paar monaten und an
dem tag hat zu hause in berlin ihr
gesundheitsminister grad vor der
flutwelle gewarnt unter war sie hier zum
abschiedsbesuch bei herrn mack orbi
sowieso
abstands er nicht so wobei einer hält
abstand herr sauer also known as der
gatte der kanzlerin
irgendwie schon auch ein besonderes foto
wenn man es ein bisschen auf sich wirken
lässt wie auch immer selbe frage hier
ist das jetzt kleinkariert darauf
hinzuweisen oder muss auch da gelten
dass wir ganz klar sagen auch bei hohen
impfquoten weiter die aha regeln
einhalten und bevor jetzt der vorwurf
kommt das ist ja alles populistisches
oder sogar irgendwie blockwart iges
politiker bashing würde ich nicht sagen
gebt mir auch fremd niemand ist page
sicher als der papst gut schlechtes bild
in diesen tagen anders natürlich kann
das jedem mal passieren dass man regeln
nicht einhält passiert mir auch ständig
und ganz klar die mehrheit der
abgeordneten der regierungsvertreter
hält sich sehr oft sehr diszipliniert an
die selbst propagierten regeln aber
wer so viel disziplin einfordert von den
menschen im alltag über so eine lange
zeit zwei jahre jetzt dann finde ich
muss man die auch selbst vorleben und
zwar nicht nur dann wenn es passt
sondern konsequent meine meinung auch
hier die frage wie seht ihr das
schreiben ja und schauen wir jetzt also
noch auf die andere veranstaltung die
die bundestagsabgeordneten der csu
hatten eine klausurtagung auch hier in
berlin gastgeber
alexander dobrindt der chef der
sogenannten
csu-landesgruppe also der der die
bundestag sonderregelung zum genesenen
status erinnert euch eher erfrischend
klar als unverschämtheit bezeichnet
hatte die einsatz voraussetzungen jetzt
hier bei der csu veranstaltung noch
strenger als bei den grünen zweig plus
negativer pcr test also genau das woran
in deutschland ja gerade eklatanter
mangel herrscht deswegen der
bundesgesundheitsminister da schon vor
wochen eine priorisierung angekündigt
hatte ganz klar ist dass hier die fragen
beschäftigten die pflege beschäftigten
die menschen der eingliederungshilfe
behindertenpflege dass die also
besonders berücksichtigt werden müssen
ja wie sieht das der gastgeber wir sind
jetzt so weit ich weiß ja alle nicht
zugehörig zu dieser priorisierten gruppe
können sie daher nachvollziehen dass das
auch manche als zwei lamas empfinden
nein kann ich nicht nachhaltig verstehe
es auch nicht die frage genau auch die
abgeordneten die hier sind haben alle
einen pcr-test gestern gemacht
und deswegen der allgemeinheit ja gerade
express tests nicht mehr zur verfügung
stehen ach so na ja das ist
privatwirtschaftlich hier organisiert
was wir haben deswegen nicht innerhalb
dessen was der öffentlichkeit im
allgemeinen zur verfügung steht und
durch die gesundheitsämter bezahlt
organisiert angeboten wird sondern dass
hier ist eine privatwirtschaftliche
angebotene möglichkeit für sie und uns
und zeigt übrigens dass man mit aller
vorsicht diese veranstaltung
entsprechend im durchführt um auch ihnen
die sicherheit zu geben dass sie durch
die teilnahme bei dieser veranstaltung
nicht in ein risiko gen infiziert zu
werden auch hier die frage an euch wie
seht ihr das schreibt uns in die
kommentare
so und jetzt zum abschluss zurück zur
ausgangsfrage
da ging ja darum dass der genesenen
status für alle menschen in deutschland
reduziert wurde von sechs monate auf
drei monate von heute auf morgen im
bundestag aber nicht warum hat noch mal
nachgefragt und da dann schriftlich
folgende antwort bekommen dass das
hygiene konzept des deutschen bundestags
tatsächlich zitat für den zugang zu
parlamentarischen sitzungen selbständige
regelungen enthalten kann
rechtsgrundlage ist das hausrecht der
bundestagspräsidentin kabel was auch
hier kann man einwenden in einer
parlamentarischen demokratie haben die
parlamentarier eben auch eine besondere
stellung genießen ja auch immunität
was jetzt nicht als wort wird es gemeint
ist sondern gemeint ist die rechtliche
immunität die gibt es tatsächlich da ist
es deswegen vielleicht sogar angemessen
dass auch hier dann mit zweierlei maß
gemessen wird oder eben nicht gerade
weil volksvertreter auch eine
vorbildfunktion haben kleiner einschub
gut möglich dass jetzt diese regelung
schon angeglichen ist zu unserem
redaktionsschluss war das noch nicht der
fall aber so oder so es hat für die
abgeordneten auf jeden fall ja zumindest
mit kurze übergangsfrist gegeben also
genau das was viele normalos ja so sehr
gefehlt hat
abschließend die frage dürfen
politikerin politikerprivilegien haben
meine haltung glaube ich dass klar
geworden wenn man so viel disziplin
einfordert über so eine lange zeit muss
man sich auch selbst an diesem maßstab
messen lassen und zwar immer wie sieht
ihr schreibt es in die kommentare
ja und wenn ihr den nächsten blick hier
durchs schlüsselloch ins berliner
regierungsviertel nicht verpassen wollte
lasst uns einen apparat und apropos
zweierlei maß wir wollen uns natürlich
auch an dem geltenden maßstab messen
also mal gucken lieber marvin haben wir
halten wir dann auch artig die 150
abstand einmal sagen oh ah
locker
185 schlecht oder
[Applaus]